guys I've had a banner week taking a lot
of naps a to Chipotle and threw up green
beer you know who hasn't had a good week
Burt Wonderstone the incredible Burt
Wonderstone turned out to be not so
incredible at the box office what
happened the billboards are everywhere
I'm standing under one right now and
they even had to make it not at all
forced totally awkward appearance on
Pawn Stars what I love about Vegas is
you never know who you're gonna bump
into are you Steve Carell no I get that
a lot
come on Steve Carell on Stars what would
Clooney do we had to know why this movie
tanked we did some hard-hitting
journalism while wearing a ridiculous
magician sure what we found was
incredible how excited are you about the
incredible Burt Wonderstone I've never
heard of it I don't even know what it is
never heard of it
oh the magician movie how excited are
you about Wonderstone not at all are you
ready to get stoned I am ready to get
stoned yes the movie the incredible Burt
Wonderstone I mean I thought he was
talking about that good good Oh Jane
oh that's sticky icky that's sticky icky
icky
you know Steve Carell nope don't know
what if I told you that Alan Arkin is in
this movie how does that grab you I have
not really that of course you know Alan
Arkin Arkin what about Steve Buscemi's
Anton marvelton wait isn't he an
Armageddon
Steve Fischetti the old guy from
Armageddon so are you more excited to
see Steve Buscemi or Jim Carrey oh my
god I got to pick one of those Oh Jim
Carrey oh yeah what can I do to get you
as excited as I am about the incredible
Burt Wonderstone uh movie trailer I
movie trailer
I could show to you on my phone so uh
witnesses coming out it's already out
okay okay and this is a true story I'm
sure it's a true story
do those remind you of any famous
magician the guy in Vegas the guy that
is there all in Vegas how excited are
you for it now well that's like love
less excited
but how did that trailer make you less
excited about the movie so you're not
excited about the movie no how many
times you think you're gonna go see uh
the incredible Burt Wonderstone maybe
one for sure
no here's the thing
Wonderstone wasn't that bad my friend
Russell saw it and told me it was okay
so that got me thinking what are some
other box-office bombs that don't
deserve to live in infamy like Pearl
Harbor not the movie
actual Pearl Harbor here's the top five
check it out
number five Speed Racer took a lot of
flak but come on people Speed Racer was
a fun acid trip one thing I will say the
Speed Racer cartoons sucked for me it
was just killing time before Voltron
number four
stay tuned first of all you gotta love
Ritter respect John Ritter hey lady
watch out
this is some funny for a kid from the
90s number three event horizon it's not
an amazing movie but it will scare the
bejesus out of you space he'll Gore fest
yeah number two
Howard the Duck two words duck boobs
whoo number one John Carter come on guys
easy to hate on this one but it's a
decent story a story that every sci-fi
movie before it stole from I'm looking
at you George Lucas plus it had the most
badass Dillon Panther of all time Tim
Riggins in it clear eyes full hearts bad
box-office so what movie do you love
that gets a ton of hey let us know in
the comments below and the best answer
gets a screen junkies t-shirt or maybe
this shirt do you want it we'll send it
to you I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for
watching
bye bye